Let's go to our voicemail.
Two one nine two.
David P is the voicemail number.
Jimmy from Philly is wondering why I didn't
cover a particular story about Bernie Sanders.
Take a listen to this.
David.
Jimmy from Philly.
Yeah.
Why have we not seen you drop a video on the
women that took Bernie's?
Mike, once again,
[inaudible]
topless.
Why have we not seen you show how weak Bernie
Sanders actually is? [inaudible] I mean this
man is that black lives matter.
People grab as Mike right now.
It's what white college girls can he list?
Grab his Mike.
What more do you need to see David to figure
out that you voted for a little bitch like
I don't understand.
Yeah, so listen, first of all, the entire,
why don't you grab the mic back thing is a
double edged sword because if Bernie doesn't
take the mic back when the mic has been grabbed
and I don't think that the topless protesters
did that.
If you don't take the mic back, people like
Jimmy from Philly say it's beta behavior.
If you do grab the mic back.
Cynical actors will say that it was a almost
a physical attack on women.
And what is Bernie doing as a man taking the
back?
So I actually understand why Bernie just walks
away when the protesters come on stage.
We just don't cover protests in this way.
Like Biden's been protested.
Bernie has been processing.
This is w what do you want me to say about
it?
Okay.
Yeah.
The Bernie was protested by topless protesters.
What's the story that, that's why we haven't
covered it yet.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
I hope you will join us there.
Become a member or a patron to get yourself
instant access.
The David Pakman show@davidpakman.com [inaudible].